what is this
happy holidays Dwayne but do not open it
till Christmas you're so pathetic how
long did this take you three hours five
minutes actually
I am a black belt and gift wrapping yeah
no such thing they don't give out black
belts for things that are stupid
well I hope it was worth it because I'm
gonna take it apart in about five
minutes
I think it'll take you a little bit
longer than that really if I can skin a
mule deer in less than 10 minutes I
ought to be able to cut mine
at least once a year I like to bring in
some of my Kevin's famous chili the
trick is to undercook the onions
everybody is going to get to know each
other in the pot I'm I'm serious about
this stuff
I'm up the night before pressing garlic
and dicing whole tomatoes I toast my own
ancho chilies
it's a recipe passed down from Malone's
for Generations
probably the thing I do best
[Music]
file
hey Dwight do you want an Altoid
what do you think
in school we learned about this
scientist who trained dogs to salivate
at the sound of a bell by feeding them
whenever a bell rang
so for the past couple weeks I've been
conducting uh similar experiment
[Music]
Dwight come on Malcolm okay
sure
and what
is
yes
[Music]
what are you doing
all right
what I don't know
my mouth tastes so bad all of a sudden
sure
you should get one of these no thank you
do you even know what this is
it is a fitness orb and it has
completely changed my life
forget everything you thought you knew
about ab workouts
done this ab workout is specifically
designed to strengthen your core
numerous health benefits
strengthens your back
performance in sports
enjoyable sex
you're not having sex
plus improved your reflexes
okay you know what uh how much is that
it's only 25 bucks wow
um okay
hey bro
listen I was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of B-25
Mitchell Panchito aircraft oh for me
don't sass me and I went to this website
and this ad popped up that said Hey Ron
Swanson check out this great offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell
like how do they know who you are
okay
um there are these things called cookies
where like if you go to a site and buy
something it'll remember you and then
create ads for other stuff you might
want to buy so it learns information
about me
seems like an invasion of privacy dude
if you think that's bad go to Google
Earth and type in your address
okay
here's the situation your parents went
away on a week's vacation they left the
keys to the brand new Porsche
well of course not I'll just take it for
a little Spin and maybe show it off to a
couple of friends I'll just cruise
around the neighborhood well maybe I
shouldn't yeah of course I should pay
attention here's the thick of the plot
pulled up to the corner at the end of my
block that's when I saw this beautiful
girly girl walking I picked up my car
phone to perpetrate like I was talking
sunroof is open the music was high in
that girl's hand was steadily moving up
my thigh she had opened up three buttons
on her shirt so far I guess that's why I
didn't notice that police car I can't
believe it I made a mistake my parents
are the same no matter time nor place so
to all you kids all across the land no
need to argue parents just don't
understand
thank you thank you
just a little something I know
so what's up uh someone is on fire in
ramsit park they need you to get down
there right away
oh my God
so while they repaint the lines in the
parking lot we're asking everyone to do
street parking I'm not street parking my
Mercedes well everyone is I'm doing it
because nobody wants to steal a Saturn
all right moving on to recycling
you okay Ron just a little tooth pain
I'm fine continue okay each department
will be getting blue bins
do you need to go to the dentist Ron I
don't like dentists just a second
hey no no no no no no no no no
[Applause]
no no
oh my God I'm sorry everybody what were
we talking about recycling dentist
pulled the tooth out yesterday
but it's always a good idea to
demonstrate to your co-workers that you
are capable of withstanding a tremendous
amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see Tom faint
[Laughter]
I found this typewriter next to the
Courtyard dumpster an old Underwood five
with original carriage return
took her home polished her up bought a
brand new ribbon off of
electronicbay.com
star headache oh he's leaving
let's go I'm gonna throw it away
no I'm not it was a billion tons what is
he typing anyway if you sense a [__]
try to remove this typewriter I'll kill
you
I'm gonna type every word I know
rectangle
America megaphone
Monday
butthole so do you recognize any of
these men I was hiding in the bathroom
stall so I didn't see his face but I
heard him he was singing along to the
music at the bar do you remember what he
was singing I think it was that song I
Want It That Way Backstreet Boys I'm
familiar okay
number one could you please sing the
opening to I Want It That Way really
okay
you are
My Fire
number two keep it going the one
desire number three believe
when I say number four I want it that
away tell me why ain't nothing but a
heartache tell me why you ain't nothing
but a mistake now number five I never
wanna hear you say
[Applause]
ah chills literal chills it was number
five number five killed my brother oh my
God I forgot about that part hey there
Boyle how was your weekend well actually
I got a little sick oh really sorry to
hear that man yeah Bullets Over Broadway
was on TV
I came down with a big old Diane Wiest
infection
like Jesus
are you eating an Italian sub for
breakfast I am but Amy said I should eat
more veggies so I got extra peppercinis
smart
excuse me you need to watch yourself I'm
sorry cup all right let's everybody just
stay calm here oh what are you gonna
arrest me for dancing
you call that dancing
this is dancing
what is happening I'm defusing the
situation
[Music]
[Applause]
oh why is my phone always dead I paid 13
for it don't worry I got it oh no my
hands are covered in butter from making
butter I'm on it Master cord mustard
Cord Camera on all right here we go
dancing over situation diffused
oh